there's no time 13 o clock Hey hail
Satan everybody yeah requests yeah I
gotta get a bunch of thumbs downs
because it's not gonna be what probably
people want to hear you know I'm gonna
have all these uh satanic black metal
guys telling me to [ __ ] off cuz I might
be you know making fun of these dudes or
whatever you know I I like heavy metal
you know else like black metal I can't
listen do you know like the venom and
Slayer you know and but you know it's
kind of time went on even like Cradle of
Filth a little bit but you know when
you're in high school all sudden girls
happen you know what I mean and you kind
of move away from metal you start going
talk more towards stuff that you know
it's talking about getting laid
rather than worshiping see soon as you
start getting laid that [ __ ] dry that
dry spell breaks you know I mean Oh
suddenly listen to those lyrics and you
go like okay yeah that's right yeah
that's that's what that means okay you
know and you want to listen to something
that the girls are gonna dig you know
cuz man back in the day you turn on that
black metal that turn those girls off
although I like some of it it's not my
me it's not my main back in those days
in hardly have any black metal girls it
was that [ __ ] was marketed towards
teenage boys well yeah I feel like
that's probably largely as you know
largely the same part of their audience
now but I feel like although I feel like
it's definitely expanded out a lot
because I feel like I know I'm I didn't
know that many metal chicks when I was
growing up but I feel like I know more
now that are little more age you're a
little bit younger so same with horror
movies I didn't know a lot of girls that
liked horror back then and was
and it was like they were it's been
around a lot longer you know and black
metal and metal itself kind of developed
better it developed and it into kind of
like a better form it started to get
kind of symphonic I like the more
symphonic kind of run you know when when
I was listening to it you know I was
probably it pitted me a black metal for
a while was was venom and that basically
that was 80s
yeah and that was like a hard version of
Motorhead really yeah and then you know
Slayer came out was a little more thrash
your version of that they were real good
too but you know some of the other stuff
just kinda generated into Cookie Monster
voices yeah what's your [ __ ] coat you
know I want to listen to the Cookie
Monster sing his [ __ ] to me devil did
you start talking about Satan it's so
tight you can't get away from Satan soon
as you start dropping the S the S bomb
on Bishop you can't talk about politics
yeah you can't talk about politics after
after that and be credible you can't
talk about women after that and be
credible you gotta stick with we're
talking about chopping women yeah it's
gotta stay strictly Satan as soon as you
bring his ass out
you know what I mean all right here it
breaks the spell I guess that's the way
you know I saw it it seems like that's
what they were doing but eventually I
got you got pretty good you know out of
it by that time yeah interesting too
because I think I mean the main period
we're gonna be focusing on it's like in
Norwegian black that the infamous
Norwegian black metal scene and like all
the church burnings and murders and
stuff like that they were that they were
responsible for and a lot of those guys
like I've been watching like a lot of
interviews with them and stuff like that
and it's interesting to me that maybe
from the outside people would think oh
that's all they listen to is like other
metal and stuff like that but that is
not the case a lot of them are super
into like old punk rock some of them are
into like death ruckus some of them
mentioned 45 grave and Christian death
and stuff like that they had I like they
were very taste in their face yeah yeah
and that they liked any kind of some of
the mutants said they liked certain
kinds of electronica it's like they
liked any kind of like extremes or
experimental a couple of them mentioned
like the Amanda glass the Swan stuff
like that and mortis started to get in
you know Sisters of Mercy style stuff
yeah and like you know he started to try
to market some of this stuff towards the
goth scene you know yes back into and
there definitely is like some crossover
with the goth metal yeah I mean we know
some people that in the goth scene that
like a lot of got music but are also
really into death metal and black band
members in you know yeah yeah chef yeah
yeah no we did his books so you know he
was cool yeah so is it now for Nia now
yeah like a lot of people that are into
that kind of stuff they're like really
nice people yeah and I think that it
kind of sucks because it was just seems
like a handful of people that were in
the Norwegian black metal scene and I'm
not saying that like some of the you
know wasn't exaggerated in the press
just like it was ever here with the
satanic panic and all of that but um a
handful of them did murder other people
a handful of them did set like 5060
churches on fire yeah and burn them down
and so some of the day did commit crimes
and go to prison and [ __ ] like that so
you know and some of them said some
really horrible [ __ ] yeah so you know
but but what's by and large every fan
I've met of that type of music has been
super super nice yeah but what's funny
though is that they had a much larger
footprint than they really were oh yeah
it was the defining scenes of Gotti
group of guys mm-hmm I mean if this has
been happening in the United States I
wouldn't even register now I would have
gone on in news a little bit did anyone
even cared about the music wouldn't
folks focused on it yeah yeah yeah it's
because it happened in the Norwegian
area that's why it got it went viral
yeah you know there was a problem there
here I don't think it would be noticed
just would've been local news well and
it seemed like it really got to the
point where I mean you can't even talk
about Norwegian black metal bands
without talking about all the other [ __ ]
that happened like no the crimes that
took place they even took and actually I
didn't know this until I started
researching the show so it's not like
I'm just trying to like cash in or
anything but this year they made a movie
about kind of the most famous murder
that happened that we'll talk about a
little bit later
and the movies called Lords of chaos and
one of the Culkin's isn't it I think
it's Rory Culkin okay playing one of the
one of the death metal or the black
metal guys so yes so I haven't seen it I
read some synopsis of it I saw the
trailer and all this other kind of stuff
but so it's kind of topical people are
still interested in it they're still
making movies about it we watched like
the documentaries we saw until the light
takes us I think that's on shutter and
we watched that and I watched like a
couple other ones that like watch some
interviews with some of the people on
everything so I've been doing that for
like before we get into this we probably
got to do some analysis the main and
aspect I would have to say that we've
monetized the channel yes if you haven't
noticed we actually took the plunge and
decided to go ahead and monetize the
channel we're gonna see how it goes
yeah it's like you know a lot of
channels are monetized and it's like it
doesn't really bother me like having to
skip through ads at the beginning or you
know whatever it is you do so we are
hoping that people are not gonna get
yeah annoyed by it we'll see if it we've
noticed that channel growth kondeh it's
getting kind of stagnant it's growing
but it's not accelerating yeah that's
because we're not monetized they you
know they don't have anything to gain
from us becoming a big channel yeah so
if we monetize they're gonna change the
algorithms most likely which they'll
promote us so you know we'll get more
subscribers which is good which would
that might reflect on patreon I don't
really think you know will ever hit
enough numbers to make a difference
insane in a in a damn YouTube check you
gotta have like hundreds of thousands of
hits I think before that he makes a
difference yeah the idea is just to help
channel growth if it doesn't make a
difference we'll probably D will
probably do monetize it again yeah we're
just working with it to see what happens
yeah so yeah if you've noticed I think I
applied for it just a few days ago and
they told me it would take a month but
it actually didn't it only took a few
days they just reviewed the channel and
most of the videos it looks like are
monetized a couple of them
said they couldn't because of we had a
very copyright issues or what am i music
and [ __ ] yeah if there was music in the
background or a picture that I wasn't
supposed to use there's no I don't know
but most of them are monetized so
hopefully it won't interfere with
anyone's like enjoyment of the show or
anything like that but we're just gonna
see how it goes
also another thing that we've been
talking about doing because you know how
the $20 nut patrons plus you know one
person that I do in a drawing every
quarter we send you free stuff like it's
usually swag from the show and
everything so what we have decided to do
just because it's kind of something that
you wanted to do because you kind of
know how to do it in also yeah also in
the long run it will probably be less
expensive for us because like drop
shipping the shirts from Zazzle or drop
shipping stuff from Zazzle is like
really expensive especially if I'm
shipping overseas so what we decided to
do was we are going to start hand
screen-printing our own shirts shirts
right we have the graphics design skills
to do it and I did it in art class back
in high school yeah so and I used to do
a lot of that [ __ ] so excreted and I
liked doing it you know I got the garage
so I'm gonna do it here Jenny I'll do
the designs
I'll do the screens and technologies and
technology has improved a lot since then
you know it looks almost kind of like
photo screen now but they'll be one
color on black the designs will be
pretty cool and the main reason why I
did it is because I had Jenny make me a
Snake Plissken shirt and the decal fell
off of it too soon like man this this
you know these Zazzle shirts are
expensive yeah and I'm not really
satisfied with the longevity of the damn
product for the amount of money that the
customer pays yeah yeah so I can make
one better than that and then we could
also sell that too yeah
to people who are not subscribers for a
fraction of that cost and it would be a
shirt - at last
yeah and I'd make sure the quality of
everything is really good so really and
it'd be uh handcrafted yeah yeah we're
just gonna make them like one at a time
in small batches
we've already will ship out time yeah
we've already planned on four designs
we're planning on doing like designs
that are different looked a little bit
different from the zazzle shirts but
also that are specific to the show
you know what I mean so we're gonna have
like the logo one we'll probably have
like a variation of the Kukulcan one
because that's kind of our thing in the
show or something
you know I might have a faceless villain
design you know things like that and
then we're going to do a new design like
every quarter and send those out to the
patrons and then we're also gonna have
probably an eBay store right where you
can buy them whatever you want to write
if you want one of the other one yeah
I'll so you're not a patron or whatever
yeah and I'll fill the order you know
when it comes in we'll send it to you
yeah but that'll end up being a much
more cost efficient yeah you know I
could probably get you a shirt like that
for $19.99 delivered yeah rather than
because some of the shirts on Zazzle
eyes are like and the zazzle shirts
things that are very fine lines the
design has a lot of fine lines on it it
doesn't last long it falls off not not
true still silkscreen it's damn in there
yeah it's double it'll never come out of
there you know I mean if I if I do it
and you can get nice fine lines and
they're strong you know they won't wash
away yeah so yeah that's it
well probably keep the zazzle store up
just because yeah it doesn't like this
because you save any bit but I'm gonna
recommend these shirts over the sale
shirts just off the top because I know
the technology yeah although there's
like I said if you want like you know a
full color design and stuff does where
you go those are like the full color one
because the screen printed ones we're
just gonna do on white on black almost
two different designs I like a t-shirt
that'll last you know 10 20 years yeah I
have some some screen print you know
silkscreen shirts that have better that
old
yeah not wearing them all time but you
know in my experience with the ones off
Azazel to date you lucky to get a couple
years out of one yeah you really got to
watch you can't like wear them a lot and
like I try to like turn them inside out
like when I wash them and stuff like
that which does make them
flogger and like wash up on channels
like : all that kind of stuff but that's
gonna happen with men yeah men throw
that [ __ ] in the wash machine how we do
it well I talk about the customer though
yeah right
yeah dudes just yeah they don't worry
about that's only as an overt active
people all right so that's something to
look forward to like I said June 15th
right around June 15th we'll probably be
sending out the first shipment to the
$20 and up patrons and also I'm gonna do
a drawing and we'll do like a little
video like we did last time for our
little winner that's under $20 okay and
also I have to give a thank you to our
newest patron his name is Jake so thank
you very much also thank you to Scott
who gave us a PayPal donation yeah these
guys also and I'm very excited about
this we got our first piece of fan art
yeah her name is Sarah and she sent us
this really kick-ass I'll put it in the
video so if you're watching on YouTube
you'll be able to see it if you're
listening to the audio you won't be able
to see it well what I'll do is I'll put
a link to her site in the show notes so
you can go like look at the artwork and
stuff like that but I thought that was
super rad she sent me this really nice
long message with the with the picture
attached I'm like oh my god I was just I
was so happy so yes so those are all the
shout outs now let's start talking about
black metal yeah now let's get a little
bit of a backer because there's a
difference between death metal and black
metal which maybe a lot of people that
aren't into they aren't into it don't
now I know it's not a huge difference
black metal satanic yeah I mean that's
pretty much the only I mean black metal
that it's usually you know it's all
satanic it's has those logos that you
can't read yeah and this is created by
the church actually a satanic panic made
that and they usually do the corpse
painting although there's a couple bands
that don't do that anymore just because
they think it's
when the satanic panic of the eighties
has gone down that the church was
jumping all over these metal bats and
everything was satanic on say it was a
very very mild well there were some
other guys that said yeah we're gonna
roll with that and they just piled it on
the well yeah yeah it was satanic bling
yeah they were and they were just trying
to you know just blowing it all out of
proportion the first one I remembered
that I was like oh yeah that's it
there's just straight-up saying that I
saw them they are considered the first
black metal yeah and yes like you are
correct enough I liked him it was kind
of like it's kind of like Motorhead but
harder yeah and it was just all about
the devil yep that's what it's all about
all about all about the devil and they
guess I got bored talking about Devils
so they have to bring in Countess
báthory then they got to bring in
vampires and they're bringing in
werewolves demons and then angels and
angels and demons fighting and yeah yeah
yeah yes Tomic warfare
yeah Tomic warfare and atomic warfare
was actually unleashing lightning Lords
from from Hell and you know it's cool
cool idea you know yeah you don't mean
fifteen sixteen seventeen it's like
badass [ __ ] you know yeah yeah backwards
who knows what's gonna buy yeah but yeah
so it's funny you should mention
Motorhead because I think they are kind
of well I think Motorhead are kind of
considered the granddaddy's of pretty
much all quote-unquote hard or extreme
metal music you know all the sudden
Akana even though it was kind of really
really hard blues really yeah it had a
sound to it and it had an image of being
very very heavy but I mean you could
argue that punk was like kind of a
speeded-up blues also have speeded up
rockabilly you listen to you listen to
you know Motorhead now and it's it's
almost like I like she I don't want to
say easy listening but just you know
yeah that's all fashion well it is very
funny because I remember when I was
growing up in the 70s and 80s and like I
had this book I didn't pay for it okay
like somebody stole it and gave it to me
but it was um it was Bob Larson that guy
he's like an exorcist or whatever and he
wrote about it is how everything is
satanic pretty much and so this book and
you know this friend like stolen gave it
to me cuz he thought that I would think
it was funny which he was right I did
and it's just this hilarious hilarious
book and like how to tell you kids a
Satanist in blah-dee-blah
and like some of the [ __ ] that he had in
there as being like satanic music you
know yeah Easter cult yeah like stuff
like that it's like even like Black
Sabbath and seven Black Sabbath or
badass and I love Black Sabbath but Lee
if you listen to them now they don't
sound that no they're not extreme it's
not really that you know it's just kind
of normal sounding it's just interesting
how you know the the boundaries have
been pushed so much that it's like you
listen to stuff that back then people
are like oh my god and now it just
sounds like oh that's catchy yeah you
put motor just listen to listen to let
me know yeah he's really the mastermind
behind a lot of it you know especially
the lyrics
let me is just talking about wisdom you
know street wisdom yeah about how people
trying to [ __ ] you over don't let him
grind you down
I love Lemmy he dead passed away you
know he went to Valhalla yeah yeah but
you know he lived a long time
considering how much whiskey you drank
yeah Lemmy was about telling you the
truth yeah in his own way it was just
seemed like a rad dude
yeah good dude and his buddy failed to
fill the animal Taylor just bust his
balls 24/7 the two of them were so funny
to his it was they should have I would
have watched like a whole like comedy
routine I had no idea Phil Taylor just
sit there just bust his [ __ ] balls
constantly taking the piss out lemme
just beaten Linda down about taking his
girlfriend and everything that's a sign
of really good buddies when they get
there but yeah so they're kind of like I
said he said they were kind of like the
granddaddy's of like like I said it was
kind of like and I think a lot of the
early medics you thrashed
and stuff like that a lot of them were
listening to punk and stuff too and that
was like some crossover there yeah Hidan
some [ __ ] like anthrax and one and all
that then you get into your death metal
which is like you know obituaries
Campbell corpse carcass all those kind
of bands now after that happened and
like you know metal starts going more
extreme in a death metal then you get
the next logical step which is just
going full-on Satanism and as far as I
know and as far as I can determine venom
are technically considered the first
black metal band and they were the ones
that came up with the name of the genre
this was in the early 80s they were
actually a British band yeah
their first album was called welcome to
hell yeah what you thought you probably
had it around here somewhere you do know
I thought it might be my dad's house oh
yeah and welcome to hell
black metal yeah that was the second one
that was 82 okay I had at war with Satan
I think it was was one of them it was it
was a double album yeah I think it
opened up what else did I have hey one
called possession from them I had four
or five of them yeah I liked them yeah I
think a lot of people did yeah I liked
them they were good I mean the thing is
is you know you say the Satanism aspect
for me it was so over the top that it
would to me it was tongue-in-cheek I
mean yeah they were taking it they
weren't ya know that that was delivered
serious but oh it's so fantastic and so
over-the-top you're like and also the
lyrics contradict each other so there
wasn't any kind of a unifying religious
theme behind it
yeah just whatever they were to tell you
in that particular song that's how that
was the story they were going to tell
you yeah know what I mean so you this is
definitely entertainment like watching a
horror movie
yeah that's what they're doing you know
which is why I I mean I never had a
brother look I said this isn't my John
rrah really it's like you know I'm into
Gotham in a Ponk I like post-punk I like
that
[ __ ] but I don't mind black metal I
don't was like I said the symphonic
stuff is actually pretty good you know
and I and I'm not gonna be one of those
people that's just like oh they don't
like so it's not music it's just noise
blah-dee-blah or that there or that
there isn't any talent behind it or it's
dumb or whatever because I mean a lot of
[ __ ] I like is dumb - and juvenile how
was thought was weird is it during the
satanic panic you know they'd have some
preacher on Geraldo or something talking
about satanic metal but then he pull out
a Rod Stewart album or a Judas Priest
album or some kiss some [ __ ] like that
but never did pull out venom yeah I'm
like were they did they not know about
that later I think they knew about it I
think they did know about it but I think
because it wasn't it was so over the top
it didn't have that low key element
where it's either trying to sneak it to
you under the radar yeah you know
they're trying to say that the
mainstream music had an underground
satanic they're trying to suck you into
it that's what they were trying to tell
people couldn't show them venom because
because it was like oh you know they're
not even being secretive yeah he's like
yeah right that's it so what I think
they're trying to do is they were trying
to say to people you good Christians who
are listening to that music you think is
harmless is actually harmful Christians
weren't listening to venom so they
didn't bring it up I think yeah yeah I
mean yeah I could see that they were
trying to get Christians to stop
listening to rock music yeah listen to
the shitty Christian yeah I think that's
right I think that's what they were
doing doing in that era I mean looking
back on it which is hilarious that you
bring that up because just the other day
I was listening to one of my favorite
podcasts which is the god-awful movies
podcast and I was listening to an old
one where they reviewed do you remember
saying eyes and I saw this like way back
in the day it was called Brock it's your
decision and it was basically about a
kid who listened to too much rock music
man yeah and he was like getting away
from Jesus and what
and so he had to like make a pledge to
like not listen to rock music for two
weeks and it was like really funny
because he was like a [ __ ] heroin
addict like he was like I'm getting the
shakes but it's like it was like that it
was like they don't know how rock music
works but um but one of the funniest
things about that was it was kind of
like you said where some of the records
that they were you know giving as
examples of like Satan sneaking into
your life is like one of them was
[ __ ] Barry Manilow Barry yeah yeah
yeah my grandma listen to the tech panic
man did weird [ __ ] to people of course
my grandma was a Satanist even did it
even did weird shift of certain bands
minds it's like one of the band's called
Stryper Stryper came out it was a metal
oh Lord I remember a Christian are they
really a metal band yeah they were they
were there was metal and I didn't really
like them that was metal I didn't like
the sound I didn't like their sound who
did nobody know they were gay there were
guys that I knew that liked it but they
were Christian guys but you know that
was what they liked that though okay but
what was weird as if some people were
saying oh well they're doing that for
the money
no I that cost them a lot of money yeah
if you are cause you were gonna do you
wanted money you should just be full-on
say yeah they really want more they
really did believe what they were saying
they really weren't Christians all right
had they not had the Christian angle
they probably would have made it a lot
bigger than probably all right and
here's another weird thing the same
churches that we're saying don't listen
to melts all Satanist we're also saying
striper was satanic yeah so you know
well they had to lay down that's a fake
Christian what are you like those really
really hardcore Christians like this
like what are they supposed to listen to
nothing the preacher like the aisle tone
the preacher you're not supposed to
listen to any music at all is it like
the funny man is it like Footloose town
they actually know dancing they have all
they have whole Christian sects they're
like that and an amazing Muslim sex -
you don't listen to [ __ ] music like
I've heard of datas devil I've heard of
that but I've never met anybody like
that and I can't and it's hard for me to
imagine in this
their Mississippi [ __ ] Mennonites and
what all the things at the end yeah yeah
but I mean they still like go out and
tool around and stuff I mean Mennonites
they still drive cars your plugs ear
plugs in their ears get back to black
metal though we are I mean good keep it
we didn't go that far out I know
yes so like I said venom is credited
with person 1982 their 1982 album black
metal that's got its name well you know
you're free to you can go listen to it
anymore
I remember when I brought this sound
recorded the sound quality's probably
terrible because it was hard back then
to listen to on the earphones yeah that
[ __ ] was recorded inside a tin can and I
think is it went on they like even if
they had the means to do it better they
wanted to look at sound shitty just look
if they wanted to be like loaf I like
that's just like the devil Devils got
some shitty shitty recording equipment
you would think the devil would have
like the best [ __ ] no bad bad to make
you suffer okay so you also had bands
like Bathory you have like merciful fate
I love mercy merciful fate were they the
first ones to do the corpse paint I mean
I know that you have had kiss and [ __ ]
like that I don't know not really the
same thing I don't know um King Diamond
I think he was kind of painting that
pain yeah I think I'm okay Fred he was
the lead lead singer of merciful fate
before you went I had that I had that
Melissa that she was [ __ ] bad yeah
yeah it was black with fire coming out
his mouth creepy and he sang a
high-pitched you know it's just weird
you know that's kind of couldn't tell
what sexy was he was like gender bending
metal style because he do the mini piece
tell him stories he did the male voices
and the female story and the female
voices yeah he's cool yeah no first time
I saw him I was disappointed it was like
an old low-budget video it's he's up on
stage he was like wearing like spandex
and [ __ ] [ __ ] he cut with Italy look
terrible yeah that's King Diamond now
later on is I really look like that like
darkness
I'm legend
I expected him to look like he ended up
looking later on you know at the top
hats and the [ __ ] real cool guy when
he actually have you got money together
he got my yeah when he wasn't just like
I never saw his ridiculous yeah like
well you know and I was listening to
except at that same time you know yeah
and a septal of much cooler even a
little odo you know Dirk Snyder he
looked kind of like a little little
[ __ ] like a little blind [ __ ] you
know I mean yeah real strong German
accent oh my gosh I start a black metal
band yeah well you accept wasn't black
metal is kind of it was like a it was
like a power metal it's kind of like a
German version of Judas Priest okay but
a little harder like more of a Metallica
edge to it they were a good band yeah
yeah yeah they never really made it they
made you know I think they had a couple
yeah I don't think most of the walls was
the only [ __ ] hit I think the head
okay I've heard that song but you know I
like that fast as a shark and all that
[ __ ] the album that came before that
I forgot what was called a long time you
had a lot of those I was into metal yeah
I was [ __ ] into battle I loved it
that's just like that cracks me up that
like cuz it cuz I didn't meet you until
like long after that time about time I
was 18 I've kind of lost interest in it
yeah yeah so yeah so like I said so
venom considered the first black metal
band now they didn't do all that well
commercially obviously um you know
really a lot of black metal bands have
it but for whatever reason they were
from the UK as I said in Norway there
was a whole scene of people that kind of
like picked up on that and ran with it
now they thought that venom was cool
they liked this satanic imagery and
stuff like that but I heard one of them
say they thought it was too showbiz yeah
that they weren't taking it seriously
and stuff so they wanted to go you know
harder more extreme faster and actually
take the Satanism seriously now there is
still some
eight over how serious I mean obviously
like I said as we'll get to some of
these [ __ ] like burnt churches
and murdered people and [ __ ] like that
but by and large I'm not sure how much
of it was yeah we actually believe in
this satanic stuff or we're just doing
it to shock people or be [ __ ] or
because people think it's scary or
whatever that's a fine line I don't know
if you want to get into it right now but
it was a synergy that had built up
between have been anyone okay well they
were already talking about Satanism yeah
okay now was you know that was the first
thing that happened and you had some of
the guys that you know they were in
bands started saying things like well
you know Christianity is not our real
religion that was forced upon us by the
church really we were we're openness
yeah okay so in a way these churches
don't belong here yeah that's kind of
what I wear a lot of it they're from
another culture yeah okay
so some of the fans these are teenage
fans would burn him down and then he
would tell the guy and then the guy
would go yeah then four churches are
burning yeah you know my guys are
burning churches but I didn't do it and
then more churches Byrd it's that kind
of synergy and they put it on the news
yeah and then they started saying on the
Norwegian news that black metal fans and
bands are burning down churches so that
just cause more of it yeah if you ask me
Matt's a saint I agree with the FBI it's
just like school shootings they had
school shootings going way way back and
weird [ __ ] to what happened people sent
in schools on fire all right back in the
old days that was only local news it
didn't go national
so they were very rare all right they
started this shooting would happen at a
school that would go nationwide and some
other loser would say well I want them
to remember me to need yes oh good idea
you're right so they're not a promoting
it that you have these in cells or other
losers you know who are willing to die
because their lives suck they want to go
out in a blaze of glory the best way to
do it is to
do what the other ones did over and over
then and the FBI told them stop we you
know FBI did a whole [ __ ] study on it
this is back that he was in the 70s
actually yeah they were like we really
should make these make news agencies
omit that from that from from or at
least like keep it locally don't name
the person don't you know what I mean
are ya ever I've said that about serial
killers Scully quit giving them badass
nicknames yeah quit you know yeah stop
it cuz it kind of glorified yeah we
might think it's horrible but to a rock
bottom loser who needs some attention
any kind of attention is good it's good
attention sir that's what they're gonna
and it's that same thing over and over
and over again
so one of these little losers who any
attention would be good for him so he
does it yeah they need to stop putting
it on TV yeah or like I said keep it
super they need to keep it maybe local
news don't name anybody ya know and if
he did that only for a couple years they
think their rates of it would plummet
yeah I've always been actually a big
advocate of not don't give me that [ __ ]
yeah don't give them attention because
that's what they want exactly they just
and it makes it happen more often yeah
just like don't even say their name just
say this loser this asshat you know this
dork yeah but it's not age of the
Internet it's gonna get out the face is
gonna get out yeah of course it's like
it's probably like you you can't like
the cats out of the bag at this house
they made it a cultural phenomenon yeah
so okay so going back now as I said
black metal starting but this in Norway
for some reason it really kind of took a
foothold and like you said it might have
had something to do with you know just
this thing where there was all these
kind of teenage guys and they were a lot
of them were living in Oslo or Bergen or
wherever which are you know very nice
cities but you know they're nice in the
sense of like being boring like nothing
bad happens there you know there's not a
lot of poverty not a lot of
you know pretty much everyone's okay
everyone's kind of normal it's not
really conservative in the you know in
one sense of the word but you know it's
not a lot exciting happens there so
maybe these guys felt like they were
bored than everything to do they wanted
to like shake things up a little bit
they wanted to get in people's faces and
like you said they had this perception
of you know they're very anti religious
which I'm not gonna [ __ ] on that because
I kind of em too but you know they had a
thing where Christianity is you know
innovating religion you know we should
all be Vikings we should go back to our
pagan roots which is another religion
really yes they were religious it was
just an alternative yeah they were anti
Christianity yeah so you know and they
kind of wanted to shock people you know
to get attention yeah so the main core
of the scene really it didn't get going
until probably like the late 80s and
early 90s now the scene in Oslo was kind
of centered around it was this little
kind of record store and it was called
held that day which means hell and it
was run by this guy named Euronymous
everybody had cool nicknames yeah you
know gods and [ __ ] well not too much
Greek gods I mean some of them had names
like necro butcher and El Hamburg well
the guys from venom had stuff like that
that's what I ain't bad and then
Poseidon and they had names like that
right it's like who knows yeah they all
had one death metal name so this guy
euronymous he actually founded the band
mayhem who were like one of the main you
know black metal bands from the area now
he had this record store I heard that he
opened it with his parents money so it
wasn't a profitable record store
obviously was not a businessman he just
basically wanted to curate the scene
pretty much it's like he just wanted you
know all these obscure you know metal
and you know noise records from around
the world they wanted to sell them to
like a kind of an elite clientele and he
wanted to like say what was
good enough to be sold in the shop and I
don't think the shop was ever profitable
or anything but it did become kind of
like this hub of like other people
hanging out there and like other bands
hanging out there I think some of even
like would live there like live upstairs
if they didn't have anywhere to go and
stuff like that so so there was that guy
Aramis and then there was this other guy
and his name was
Varg Bakr nice and he kind of moved the
curtis and he kind of went by the name
count grishnak he is actually still
around and he has a YouTube channel and
I watched a couple of the like little he
talks about metal and he talks about
other [ __ ] he did kill a guy so there
was that but yeah so so the the store
opened I think in like the summer of
1991 and over the next couple years you
know the the scene starts kind of
growing in this area they all had these
names like I said you got your
Blackthorne you got your occultists you
got all those kind of people you got
like they all had those logos and it's
funny because I do you know I'm a
graphic designer and one of my friends
she manages like a lot of death metal
bands here in Florida because there's
actually a really big death metal scene
here in Florida which I don't know if
you knew that or not but so there we do
we have a lot of shows here in Orlando
so I do a lot of posters for them and I
always like crack up because she sends
me like the logos for these bands like
to put them on the posters and I'm like
what is it we're doing a show on there's
no region black metal stuff look she's
kind of busting on it a little bit I
understand it I used to be into it I
understand it he's the black metal lady
for making your album covers how many
hours you think you've done I don't know
how many different bands a lot a lot of
them right yeah yeah she's the one
making all the album covers those damn
fonts you can't read you think looks a
bunch of blood yes you did is it
yeah yeah I like doing that kind of
stuff yeah she makes the album covers
yeah all right well which advance just
off the top do you think that you died
that you've done you done with sons of
ragnar right yeah it's not the Ragnar
they're like Viking
yeah well you've done a bunch of
withering earth went wither and earth oh
gosh
I know I've done a couple more than that
I can't remember camera yeah but yeah a
lot of their fliers and stuff yeah I
usually do the posters like if they do
shows here I've done some of their album
covers and [ __ ] like that yeah yeah
they're cool black metal record labor
lady well here yes in Central Florida
yeah I'm not sure I'm not [ __ ] not I
like the music I'm talking about that
I'm talking about these people in
particular you know I mean and some of
the other people seemed cool like when I
watched interviews with them and stuff
him to say that one guy and that one guy
like killed a dude so you know yeah you
tell me a story about a black metal
record that she did one time they they
sent her a picture of what they wanted
and they just wanted a description they
wanted it had to be like and I'm going
that's the that Stonehenge that's that's
from whoops name of that damn movie [ __ ]
they made the little yeah I know spinal
taps I'll chat they gave a description
it's like straight out of spinal tap you
know we want you want elves we want no
we want we want that well I appreciate
it it on hand we wanted at night wanted
lightning we want it with demons and and
it was it with some sun rays and but she
made it work how about that near like
yeah that came out beautiful yeah even
well no because here's the thing it's
like I I told them it's like I
appreciated I mean because with the
instructions they spent we're like very
very specific which in some ways is like
a pain in the ass because it's like oh
now I have to like do all this Photoshop
work but in another way that's really
cool because it's much better than
somebody's just like oh just do whatever
I'm not really sure what I want yeah but
they know what they don't want so like
all deuces so I have no idea like what
direction to go and I'll do something
I'm like no not that right but then they
don't give you it and then you just like
no not that either so I'm just like yeah
that's not they told you what they
wanted and that's what I mean they knew
exactly what they wanted and that's
awesome but yeah I think it came out
really good so yeah so all these bands
and they're doing
a corpse paint kind of thing which that
they started doing that like a couple of
the bands don't do it cuz I thought I
think they thought like oh it's too
trendy and now everyone's doing it but
they did that to differentiate
themselves from death metal because it
was like a really big death metal scene
in Sweden at the time and they wanted to
differentiate because I didn't know this
until I watched like a couple these
documentaries but the Norwegian black
metal dudes hate the Swedish people yeah
it's like they're just like oh they're
all [ __ ] yeah it's like they're all
they're doing is like [ __ ] on Swedes
and like some and the Swedes like hate
them right back oh just like the Swedish
death metal though they'll put their
bands out managed to be like you know
that's not the Norwegians and all this
other so it's like this big bribe they
don't like to danish either so there's
like these big like metal between it's
kind of like the hip-hop beefs you know
it's like East Coast West Coast but it's
just like our way versus Denmark vs.
Sweden right and they're just all like
making snarky little comments about each
other like oh they're like labels it's
like really funny alright so now let's
talk about kind of one of the first one
of the first things that sort of made
the scene change and go toward probably
like a more got a criminal direction or
you got them like more attention this
was actually not a murder this wasn't a
suicide now this guy was named and I'm
please I'm sure I'm butchering this
pronunciation but his name was pear and
BAE Olin and actually he was known as
dead he was 22 years old now according
to everyone that knew him he was a very
depressed it's like he was very
death-obsessed that's like all he talked
about
he was into like self-harm he was always
like cutting himself like you know at
parties like to get attention and
whatnot
he's kind of the one that I think he was
one of the first ones that was to do the
corpse paint thing so he's kind of like
given credit with like kind of bringing
corpse paint to the wider like black
metal scene just kind of a big thing for
them so he also had a thing where he
would collect
dead birds like collect efforts and like
keep them in a bag and like keep them in
his room and yeah awesome and huffin
like before he would go on stage and
stuff he's like oh I want to sing with
like the smell of death in my nostrils
or whatever and he you know he'd burn
like quick decapitated pig heads on
stage loved stage shows and stuff like
that so he was the lead singer of mayhem
for a while which it was Iran emphasis
band your honor miss spoiler alert he
gets murdered later on so this is mayhem
they are living up to their name as you
said you see now the thing about death
is that he said and I don't know if this
is true or not but he said that when he
was 10 years old that I think it was his
spleen ruptured and he had a near-death
experience and that was what like gave
him this obsession with death like
throughout his life so I so I don't know
why how true that is but that's what he
always used to tell people anyway so
he's 22 years old he finally decides
he's gonna kill himself I guess your
anima s' is at his house and I'm not I
wasn't there so I don't know exactly how
this went down
but apparently dad's like yeah I'm gonna
kill myself here I'm just like go for it
I can't even like tell him not to he's
like do it do it do it yeah yeah so he
did oh yeah apparently he cut his wrists
I think he slashed his throat and that
didn't work and so he blew his head off
with a shotgun yeah so yeah that was in
1991 now were they drunk ah not that I
ever heard of so he does that dates they
would call that negligent homicide yeah
killing somebody by net by not
preventing it yeah
well listen to this [ __ ] that happened
afterward okay so dad blows his head off
Euronymous like I said he was either
there when it happened or he got there
right when it was happening or whatever
it was
now story goes that he sees the dead
body and he goes down the street to the
store he buys a portable camera comes
back kind of poses some [ __ ] or on the
body takes a picture
of the body and uses that as the cover
of their bootleg live album yeah which
sorry core that's pretty hardcore
although those dudes would have a lot
would have wanted that
probably I've heard and I think that
that I think that this was that this was
dead suicide I think that he left a
suicide note but all it said was sorry
about all the blood Cheers
I think that's all it said but okay so
not only did he take a picture of the
dead and I've seen the cover it's pretty
gross yeah he took a picture of it and
put it on the cover of their live of
their live bootleg but he also took part
of a little shattered pieces of his
skull like from his head being blown off
and made jewelry out of it and gave it
to friends of his that he thought were
that he had deemed worthy and like cool
enough to get one okay now that is true
there is also a legend edge lured by the
[ __ ] but there's also a legend that
he collected pieces of Dead's brain and
made a stew out of it and ate it I'm not
sure if that's true but the bone thing
is true because some of the other people
like corroboree people know why Viking
warriors were so [ __ ] crazy with the
blood eagle and you know making children
fight each other to the death captured
captive sacks and children really make
them fight to the death stuff like that
you know they were guys like this is
their and that's exactly what yeah I
think that's kind of what these dudes
are like shooting for because a lot of
them especially that Varg guy after
tribal identity yeah yeah it's like he's
very into the Viking thing and actually
some of the death metal bands that we
have here in Florida are very until like
the Viking thing and you know a couple
of the ones that I've done album covers
for and like their lyrics and stuff it's
it's very very Nordic very you know
Viking ancestors and we're gonna [ __ ]
everybody up yeah so I think that's
where this is coming from yeah although
you know it's funny you you you the
interviews I've seen these guys they're
little guys they're not even big guys
four Norwegians a lot of
yeah you know they're not physically
intimidating
well most Armour just like skinny longer
you know just like they're just like
heavy metal guys are every year and
pretty much the world over yeah I feel
like eat some [ __ ] yeah even some
brains do yes yeah that's I mean it's
funny to me that you know it yeah it's
been corroborated that he made necklaces
out of the parts of this dudes skull but
it's like oh then they're like oh we not
if we're not sure if he did the brain
stew thing I'm like would it really be
that much farther along than the skull
thing or gonna this I mean yeah but but
I can see if it's like once you've
already like taking bits of the dudes
skull and made necklaces out of it I
don't really see it's not that much
farther to go to like make a [ __ ]
steel out of the brain either you
already you already poking around in
there what happened next well actually
what happened next is that we need to
take a break because we're on this so we
haven't even got to like the murder yet
it's an hour yeah it's just about yeah
all right so we are gonna take a break
right now when we come back we will talk
a little bit more about the Norwegian
black metal scene all the church
burnings and some of the murders and
stuff like that so we'll be back in just
a minute
the faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest unsolved murders of the 20th
century volume 2 includes cases spanning
the years from 1960 through 1979
featuring such infamous crimes as the
triple homicide at Lake Bodom the family
massacre known as the good heart murders
the serial killings of the Zodiac Bible
John Jack the stripper and the freeway
phantom the slaughter of dozens of women
and girls along the highway of tears and
the Texas killing fields and the
mysterious death of suspected spy the is
doll woman along with dozens of other
fascinating and horrifying accounts by
it now from Amazon in print Kindle or
audiobook format
what you doing you doing booster food
being miss that's Kitty Craig yeah
that's all she wants to use those dip
treat yeah yeah all right we're back
talking about Norwegian black metal yeah
now before the break we were talking
about the suicide of the man known as
dead and his photo appearing on the
front of the like album which was
actually called dawn of the black hearts
I didn't remember before the break but
now I remember now this was kind of like
it seemed like this was a turning point
in this Norwegian metal scene now it
should be noted that this scene as you
said was actually really small it was
kind of mostly based around this record
store you know held that day which was
also the headquarters of deathlike
silence records which Iran is also
founded and it was probably only like
15-20 like main players and then like a
bunch of kind of people around it so it
was just like you know a scene a small
scene was just like a bunch of bands and
they all kind of knew each other so
after dead committed suicide and
Euronymous took the photo of him and did
the thing with the skull necklaces and
all that there was kind of like a rift
developed in the scene because some
people thought it was cool and some
people thought it was [ __ ] up so you
know then there kind of started to be
like all this sort of infighting and
there was always that all that kind of
[ __ ] to now it should be noted to that
euronymous
from everything that I've read about him
he was kind of more they always say
stuff like the scene isn't like really
political but some of the stuff that
they talked about was kind of like now
euronymous seemed like he was kind of
like a Stalin type of admirer he was
like a hardcore like communist he want
he was really into totalitarianism of
that type but then you get like Varg who
was from the band versum and he was
actually more of like a more of like a
neo-nazi so they kind of didn't get
along on that or versus Nazis dichotomy
yes there was that a kind of whole thing
going on to some of the fans just wanted
to stay out of it they just wanted to
you know play music and be Satanists or
you know do satanic [ __ ] and not worry
about it but there was kind of like that
sort of rivalry going on there too so um
and like I said it's kind of like
there's not even really agreement on and
Euronymous in particular and they talked
about him a lot because he's you know
one of the ones that got murdered and he
was the one mainly that the movie Lords
of chaos is about just kids getting out
of control
yes she's she found a box full of like
all other boxes and plastic except she
was like what she found a box of boxes
yeah and plastic bags and she's like oh
boy look Katie you're on the show what
do you think about black metal maybe
cookie no answer baby cookie she's gonna
know yeah so like I said there so
there's no really agreement on even
Euronymous you know some people said oh
the SATA satanic thing it was just all
for show and some people said no he
totally was a Satanist he didn't he
really did believe in that and it should
be noted too that when they're talking
about being Satanists what they were
trying to put across whether they
genuinely believe this or not was what
they would call theistic Satanism as
they thought that Satan was a real being
that could be you know summoned whatever
it wasn't a type of thing like here's
the weird thing you know what it wasn't
like the Satanic Church nowadays which
is more or less atheistic or agnostic
Italy there's a weird thing they're
saying that they that Christianity
doesn't belong there that they're
actually more like Vikings but then
they're talking about they they which is
eight which is the Christian contrition
concept or any sense
no it doesn't because maybe says well
like I said I think I mean if they
thought they were if they thought they
were Vikings
and then they thought Satan was real it
wouldn't be the Christian state it would
be the Vikings Satan which was that damn
king of the ice giants at the North Pole
yeah
what's his name he they had some weird
and they farm mirrors refer why would he
be worried about yes that's why I mean
that's why I'm I suspect that a lot of
them just got into it because of Al you
because I mean they were basically just
trying to you know much like Punk was
they were just anti anti authority they
just wanted to like shock people and
getting people's faces and like piss off
the squares or whatever the [ __ ] they
were doing so they were gonna use and I
think they flirted with a lot of Nazi
imagery to maybe not because they were
actual Nazis even though your honor us
thought that a lot of them were but you
know just to piss people off is what
they were trying to they were trying to
provoke people and some of them have
said as much that that's what they were
trying to do that they weren't really
taking it all that seriously but you
know so in right around 1992 is when all
the church burnings started to happen
and these went on for a period of about
four years off and on for like 1992 to
1996 the ones that they know of there
have been at least fifty now not and a
lot of the churches were like burned to
the ground and these were like old you
know churches like historic churches and
some of them are gone now because of
this every single case of arson that was
solved it
was a black metal guy it was either
somebody in a band or a fan of one of
the bands you know what's interesting is
when I was looking when I was
researching this I found an article from
just a couple months ago I think it was
from March of 2019 and there was a kid
in Louisiana who was going around
burning black churches and they caught
him and he was also a black metal fan
yeah and he was a big fan of that that
Varg fella and so he was going around
burning churches I guess four and then I
guess it was kind of a racist component
to but also because because this it
should be said that when all these
churches started getting burned
it's like cuz here's the thing I you
know I'm not a Christian and I'm not
really I'm not down with it um but I
would never burn down like a beautiful
100 year old but it's not the buildings
fault insane that's crazy yeah you know
what I mean it's like and what does it
do
you're just you're not doing anything
yeah productive you know what I mean
yeah most of southern church burnings
like Utama was political it wasn't even
really religious it was white Christians
burning down black churches yeah not
because of Christianity because they
believed northern political agents were
working through those churches that was
back then in the 60s yeah that's why I
never did it yeah there wasn't it was it
was more about politics yeah they didn't
want Yankees using them as bases of
operations basically what they were
saying well this is this was in general
this is the Klan that was doing this
yeah but not just the Klan it was other
ones too yeah cops did it back in those
well yeah well some cops were in the
Klan yeah but some cops weren't in the
Klan well he'll burn him down because
Yankees we're taking over those churches
and you know riling up the black people
that's that's how they perceived it but
this kid that they caught I mean he was
21 years old and he was all into black
metal and he was all into like church
burning and stuff like that so they
suspect that it probably had something
to do
yeah so as I said that you know of the
50 or so cases that they solved you know
every one of them was either a fan or a
band member
now Varga Kurtis he is actually
suspected of burning down fan tops spant
oft stave Church which that was the
first one that they solved because he
had his bands EP which was called ashes
except in Norwegian had a photograph of
that church burning down he was not
making a super secret about it and when
it comes out it's like oh those churches
are burning down they're like yeah good
they didn't like think it was bad or
nothing and they were just like yeah
that should happen because Christians
suck and or just like build all the [ __ ]
down um so he was suspected of that one
but wasn't convicted of that however in
1994 he actually was convicted of
burning down a home in : Chapel another
church called skilled church and another
one called asan may I guess that's how
you pronounce it so he got three church
burnings but they suspect him and a
bunch more so it's not just the fans
that like this dudes in a band too and
he's out there burning churches done now
something that he was allegedly planning
to do was that he and euronymous were
going to blow up
maderos cathedral that was gonna be like
their album release party well they were
gonna like they put a picture of the
cathedral on the cover but they had
planned to blow it up and apparently
they were gonna go through with it
because I think when var got arrested
for for murder I think it was when he
got arrested for the murder they found
like a whole [ __ ] ton of like explosives
like in his house so he was planning on
doing this [ __ ] yeah notoriously light
sentences up there yeah well you can't
get any more than 21 years for murder
yeah that's like that's the maximum
sentence right and you probably get half
off for good behavior yeah
I think well for a murder I think he's
[ __ ] he didn't do the whole 21 years but
he did 15 years something like that you
get here he's out now but that's what
you get here was a ransom yeah yeah yeah
you get that for grand theft here Oh 15
is nothing in some of these states yeah
it might have been longer but I can't
really remember but yeah so there were
um there were some other band members
that were also convicted of burning
other various churches so never got
caught some of them were just like fans
of the bands and [ __ ] like that and you
know none of them were sorry obviously
they just said no well Christians
shouldn't be here it's like we should
all be Vikings we should go back to our
pagan roots or whatever so we're just
like rooting out the yeah the
interlopers or whatever that's how they
saw it
so robably a time where there's just
like a massive amounts of atheism there
anyway I think those churches are pretty
much just monuments weren't it well yeah
that's what I mean and I don't think
people were bothered because uh
Christianity I mean Norway is one of the
most a theistic societies on earth I
think Iceland might be number one but
Norway's up there when you start burning
these churches down it becomes a
cultural phenomenon that's what they're
that's what's happening it was kind of
like that in the south when that when
church burnings were real common yeah
nowadays every now and then one might
happen because it was a cultural
phenomenon yeah somebody says remember
we used to burn churches down let's burn
a church down let's do that again do
that again yeah it's just that dumb just
to me it just seems dumb and it just
that dumb not yet I don't know it's I'm
the kind of like I'm a very black out
tipping yes it is it's exactly like that
yeah it's exactly like that yeah it's
like I don't know what it is that you
think you're accomplishing but it's
nothing you're not accomplishing
anything
it's young men but not much to do yeah
clearly yeah it's just I don't know it
and even when I was younger like I've
always been a very pragmatic person I
don't really like things that don't have
any effect or don't you know what I mean
it's like if you want to fight
Christiana
let's say let's say I don't like
Christianity and I don't think people
should be Christians or whatever it's
like there's better ways to go about it
than burning churches down you know what
I mean much better ways I mean there's
like hundreds of better ways to go about
it than burning churches there's no
reason to fight Christian and there's no
reason to anyway and especially in
Norway like I said it's one of those
atheistic countries on earth they're
probably just mad because hey that was a
beautiful building and why did you [ __ ]
it up
me and Jenny went through the worst of
it the satanic panic looking back I
don't we just laugh at they can't do
anything to you
yeah they can't drive you crazy pull
your posters off the wall we need a kid
and the thing about it is that most of
the satanic panic stuff like you said
all the all the [ __ ] they were
complaining about was just regular [ __ ]
it was just fun you know it's like they
were always like [ __ ] on people with
like like in horror movies and [ __ ] like
that it's like it's not satanic about it
it was a cultural phenomenon it was like
there was a generational there was a
generational differences and yeah that
generation is mostly gone so you have to
worry about it anymore
yeah I just feel like as time goes on I
just feel like people are just gonna be
like man it was a Boomer thing I
definitely think it was a it was a
building thing because I feel like and
we've talked about this a lot but I
definitely feel like remember how there
used to be and maybe our generation
we're generation accent maybe this was
the last one to really have this was I
feel like we're the last ones to
experience like a really profound like
generational generation gap right I feel
like there's not we had generation gap
there's not really much like that
anymore I mean I think I feel like we're
the last I know that everybody like when
they're a teenager like every so my
parents understand me and blow a lot I
think that's probably gonna go on
forever but I don't think there's this
kind of like of this whole zeitgeist
kind of shift like Francis we never
listened to our parents of music really
not really really well my dad was into
good ships especially not our
grandparents music well no no but we can
go to club today hang out people in
their 20s and all sudden their bring it
up musically how do you know about that
yeah how do you cuz they're listening to
the lobby I found that very weird
they're listening to the same [ __ ] we
were listening to yeah I find that very
weird you know
and didn't used to be that way just goes
our our generation started to have good
aesthetic taste in things they kind of
stood the test of time they didn't go
out of style
maybe we're not quite as lame as like
old people or this like man I'm still
lame cuz I'm you know cuz old people are
always kind of they get lame as they get
older but I feel like maybe we're less
lame those names that all people I'm
generation it was at least we kind of
keep up with [ __ ] with a certain kind of
expectations of life that aren't really
realistic by today's standards and they
were very much inside the box yeah maybe
that's what it was maybe it's just
because like their institutional we were
sort of the first ones to bust the box
out and we no one could really put the
box back together the way it was so I
saw the box was broken by the time I was
19
yeah it's like oh that [ __ ] won't last
yeah and I mean you know adults would
give me advice and I'm like yeah that
advice isn't gonna be good for much
longer
yeah because I we saw technological
changes coming and societal changes and
you know just how the economy was
changing well you know I was expected to
do things that my grandfather did don't
like yeah and I feel like we were the
first ones to see that it's like they
don't have to won't you have to keep
changing you have to fun your toes like
all the time not only my grandfather my
father would never be able to imagine
you could make money off the internet
and he said yeah make money off the
internet but he couldn't explain to you
how that's actually done well your dad
doesn't even use the inside news the
Internet does he my grandmother goes on
it's all [ __ ] so what the Internet's
[ __ ] yes although it's a that's
really funny i stratum you know showed
him YouTube because he likes gods and
[ __ ] I said what kind of thing you want
to see what's the weirdest thing you
know what's the what what what kind of
information do you want there's like
rare guns from like the 20s or 30s or
something you know and I remember I just
started finding whose yeah that's it
right there been looking for one of
those
yeah just stuff like that and yeah just
impressed him again there's knowledge on
there yeah yeah he just thought it's
just [ __ ] what did he think I was
just born yes a people I saw people
lying yeah
yeah porn people lying most of it is all
porn but you know I think 80% of its
born but there's some interesting [ __ ]
getting rezoned you could actually do
research from there but you know the
idea of eBay would blow his mind
the idea of PayPal the idea of oops
making electronic transfers through your
email accounts into your [ __ ] bank
account it blows mine well the weird
thing is that I mean you and me we
didn't grow up with that either
I didn't start using computers at school
until I was eight and even then it had
the big five and a quarter floppy it was
like a Mac Apple 2e or something like
that when I was eight years old um you
know and I got started early I didn't
really see you but you know but we
didn't grow up with it so we were like I
was probably in high school or college
before I really got into like using
computers and the internet and stuff
like that but even we adapted pretty
quickly it's like oh this is how it is
now okay yeah I didn't see the internet
until like about 95 96
yeah it should have made me pry around
25 or something like that yeah and I
bought something off of Hot Topic it
blew my [ __ ] mind I ordered show on
this saying and push the buttons and
then it comes to me yeah it's like some
[ __ ] was like smash it out of [ __ ]
our [ __ ] size it was it was just like
what I saw in the running man when
Arnold Schwarzenegger buy sick airplane
ticket to Hawaii on its TV through Web
TV yeah not cuz I've made the purchase
through Web TV yeah I think we we
bypassed Web TV like I'd heard of it I
knew some people that had it but we
didn't and then we just went right it
was a good idea at the time it was so
expensive yeah you web TV for like 120
bucks yeah and get on the internet yeah
it was awesome I couldn't believe it
that's not mine it's not as much on the
Internet you couldn't stream back then
yeah there was a lot of [ __ ] you
couldn't Lodge it was it was even more
shitty than a cell phone yeah but in
those days you could just it was well it
was a big deal because you didn't have
to go
house to show yeah sounds like what I
was of yes yes I was like in Gulfport
Mississippi and I could order something
from England yeah you know from remember
Black Rose mhm
those gothic clothes some black room
black ice to get him out of the catalog
yeah that's my mama's [ __ ] blind
snail-mail I was dressing good yeah oh
yeah but yeah so where was I
okay so now before the the big iconic
murder that everybody there was actually
another murder and this is another thing
that kind of makes me feel like yeah you
guys are maybe not so cool so in 1992
this one guy his name is Faust he was
walking home one night through
Lillehammer and according to him he was
approached by this 42 year old man who
was gay man and he says the guy
propositioned him I'm not sure I buy
that but Faust decides hey I've always
wanted to know what it would be like to
kill a person so he just stabbed the
dude to death
yeah 37 times today we kill the gay
because it robbed
I guess what the [ __ ] man yeah so he
stabs the guy 37 times just in the
street just random guy walking by and
then when he's on the ground like
bleeding to death then he starts kicking
him yeah until he's dead yeah I'm like
fantastic so they catch him and criminal
mastermind that he is yeah and his quote
was I was outside just waiting to get
out some aggression yeah it's not easy
to describe why it happened it was meant
to happen and if it was this man or
another man that's not really important
all right well I guess it's not
important to you is it it was important
to that guy yeah and his family the guy
say there's a Jew Lord so you know not
so cool just going around randomly
stabbing gay dudes to death on the
streets of Lillehammer yeah
so yeah now the media kind of had a
field day with this and like I said this
is a [ __ ] horrific crime and it's
horrible but you know you know they play
up the Satanism angle and I'm not really
sure you know how much that can be I
mean this dude is obviously just a lot
of these dudes that are into this kind
of [ __ ] and like I said the music is
cool it's not so much that but these
dudes that get so into it that they're
willing to like [ __ ] stab people to
death I mean obviously that's nothing to
do with the music that is a messed up
individual the dudes are sitting around
talking too much yeah they're not doing
enough [ __ ] talk about [ __ ] records they
talk about each other then they start
talking about talking each other into
this weird [ __ ] zone then they go out
and [ __ ] do some stupid [ __ ] like
this dudes need to be in the arm and
they need to be working then boys is
what they is well I mean like I said
like they said it do some [ __ ] it feels
like something that you know some in
their lives yeah it's like maybe they
don't feel like they have a purpose or
they don't have a life or or baby they
have emotional problems that are like
untreated and not doing anything I'll
give you emotional problems that's a
thing all that [ __ ] plays into itself
you put a person in solitary confinement
its anus [ __ ] the world a few
years later he's [ __ ] weird yeah so
it is
ya know you take these guys well humans
are meant to be interacting with other
uses doing thing and have
accomplishments and and you know well
you put a bunch up together in this
little clique it's already kind of
negative and they're all kind of
reinforcing that you know everyone sucks
yeah yeah and then next thing you know
they're doing stupid [ __ ] like this how
many girls are in this scene that's what
I mean not a lot yes so they're not
surprising so basically we're talking
about basically talk about incest well
and one of the other guys too and I
can't remember what his name was but um
one of the other guys too he actually
got arrested later for beating up his
girlfriend now he was in his 40s and the
girlfriend was in her 20s I think she
was 26 or something and he beat her up
and then raped her with a tattoo gun
what damn so yeah he got him while I was
running I guess I didn't really precise
read like a thing I
that's charming yeah so you know beating
up girls beating up gay people that's
you know like I said they're not all
like that and it's nothing to do with
the [ __ ] music like I said it's just
these sounds like the synergy is the
synergy of this little scene working on
itself yeah losing if you ask me and you
know no Fitz if you're in these Nordic
nations out you know I went to I went to
high school in Brazil with people from
Sweden and Denmark you know they were I
went to an international high school you
know and you know they told me about
what was like and you know I've known
some goth dudes you know in Boston you
know like coming down from Sweden it's
boring there no I don't mean to insult
but you know they they tell you Sweden
Denmark Norway kind of boring yeah well
I said that earlier it's like it's just
a play so like not a lot exciting yeah
not a lot going on there all right
they come to the United States they
think it's like a [ __ ] amusement park
okay they just love it they go crazy a
lot of them a lot of them if they fit in
well they don't really want to go back
but most of them have to go back for one
reason another school family you know
plus they're not really used to some of
the hardships you know that mean yeah
United States you gotta figure out a way
to make a living yeah there they don't
really have to yeah I mean they had they
had a good dough long as you could say
well yeah they have a good subjects
right I mean here not you you lose your
job you're kind of [ __ ] yeah they're
not really used to I've been there yeah
they're not really used to kind of like
the Wild West element of the United
States you know to be aware if you fail
you're [ __ ]
yeah you're [ __ ] here you're sleeping
in an alley yeah you better learn you
better to learn use of Street skills
it's sad but it's true there's Street
skills so like I said so it's these guys
like doing this kind of [ __ ] now it
should be noted that Faust the day after
he stabbed this poor man he goes to hang
out with euronymous and Varg and the
other guys and they go and burn one of
them churches down the holmenkollen
Chapel like I said before so he was in
on that too allegedly but then they
caught him a little bit later he got 14
years he was let out into that
and three like I said he never he never
showed any remorse he never really had
any reason he's like I was just walking
down the street and I felt like he was
into serial killers and I just wanted to
see what it was like to kill a person
which again what the farm so yeah and
then again like I'm into serial killers
- I'm into horror movies I'm into [ __ ]
like that but like I don't want to do it
in real life you don't to meet them
[ __ ] no it's like why would you
it's just it's escapism in a weird way
it's like I don't really want to do any
of that [ __ ] and most people that are
into that [ __ ] don't want to do any of
that Jen kind of [ __ ] that's why I try
to like differentiate between because I
know how vilified you know people who
like horror movies have vilified people
who like to goth people like you know
there's like oh you're Satanists and
you're serial killers all this other
kind of [ __ ] where most of the people
that are into it are like the nicest
people ever it's just this little tiny
percentage of weirdos that would be
weirdos anyway like whatever scene they
were into because they have other
[ __ ] problems
so guys with caddy though most them well
yeah yeah so I mean the media had been
kind of jumping all over you know the
suicides the church burnings all this
other kind of stuff but I think it was
really 1993 before it kind of went
nationwide and worldwide because there
was a bunch of articles about it
especially in one of it like there was a
big newspaper in Norway Kerrang you know
the very famous metal magazine out of
the UK they did like a huge thing about
it which was a little bit
sensationalized I actually I read it
it's on its online the whole thing is
but so a lot of it was sort of
exaggerated and I think that the guys in
the bands they kind of contributed to
that a little bit too because whenever
they got interviewed particularly in
their early days you know they wanted to
make it seem like they were as scary as
possible so they might have you know
embellished some [ __ ] - even though I'm
not saying that they didn't do like the
[ __ ] that they were accused of doing but
they embellished other things now
Varg was actually interviewed for this
one
Euler paper and this was a really famous
article and like I said that's kind of
what got the genre nationwide attention
and he actually confessed in the article
that he had burned all these churches
and he took credit for killing the guy
in Lillehammer
even though Faust had done that so he
also you know said that they were
Satanists and you know all we want to do
is just you know spread evil and fear
and that's kind of our whole mission in
life and all this other [ __ ] now the the
people that wrote the journalist that
wrote the article actually went to the
cops and said hey this guy that I talked
to you for this article like he admitted
to doing all of this crap came out and
well and the cops well the cops were
already suspecting him anyway
but they found out where he lived
because Varg had printed these flyers
for his band and he had his home address
on them so they just found one of the
players they said oh he's in this band
and where he lives they turn up and
they're like hey man yeah he's no Batman
now that same year Euronymous he was the
one that owned the store how vete were
all the people gathered and stuff at
this point like they kind of had the
media sniffing around the cops were
sniffing around because you know a lot
of these people that they were
suspecting of doing all of this [ __ ]
were hanging out in this one place so
they kind of had it under surveillance
so he decided that he was gonna close
the shop it wasn't making any money
anyway and that was never really the
intention I guess for for the place and
this kind of pissed Varg off a little
bit because he he thought and I think
this may be why he had like embellished
some of the [ __ ] in the articles was
that he wanted all of this [ __ ] - just
go worldwide in the media because he's
like this'll make people buy the records
right which I guess worked in a way
because I don't think anybody be talking
about these bands maybe because it was
like I said it was a tiny underground
team but if some people know about these
bands just because of all this horrible
[ __ ] that happened at all the media
surrounding it so I think he wanted to
use all of that to sell
curds so he was pissed off that your
honor was said you know it's there's too
much heat on the shop I'm gonna close it
so then that was like even more a little
rivalry going on there so Varg
eventually goes to prison and he's all
he said some [ __ ] like he was trying to
get and I don't know if he really did
this but he was trying to get the police
he's like oh that the prisons in Norway
are too nice it's like we actually get a
toilet in a bed it's like I told him to
throw me in a dungeon and beat me up and
they wouldn't do it and also they're
kind of [ __ ] so I said and he's you know
sent around to go and he's got guns and
chainmail and swords and all those other
concha so you know send me to a
Nicaraguan prison which is funny because
I suspect that if you really send him to
like one of those shitty prisons like
what's that [ __ ] reality show that we
see sometimes like locked up abroad yeah
I suspect if you set him to one of those
prisons he'd be the first one
yeah they do they down me in jail in Sao
Paulo man whoo didn't they have an
episode about the hog man it's dudes
hanging it's just big cells made for
maybe four people with 20 30 people in
there yeah got the toothbrush hanging
from the ceiling on a [ __ ] cord they
all use the same toothbrush they've made
hammocks so they could pack more people
in they're [ __ ] terrible terrible
damn those lights so it's dark in there
mold growing yeah yeah man so like I
said I'm kind of curious yeah like if
they actually had put this part put this
guy he would have crack in this print
like a real prison quote unquote yeah
instead of one of those cushy Norwegian
prison yeah if you went to prison in
Saddam's Iraq all right they did weird
[ __ ] to you
okay if you went to a burger rib they
torture you and then at the end of the
day they'd hand a noose and the news had
a clip on it and you could clip it onto
the ceiling and hang yourself they were
gonna give you a choice to kill yourself
yeah yeah but they would you
/ pack them in there and do weird [ __ ]
like take a damn rubber hose to suck it
slip it up in your ass and pull it out
so hard - pulley prolapsed you call it
out yeah yeah not my choice I just yeah
that's how they did that yeah you know
what happens to those searches oh yeah
some of those countries if you're going
to if you go to jail they mean to kill
you that they're they hope you're not
coming out of there alive
yeah they don't have to keep feeding you
you costing too much money yeah you did
Slyke population control yeah all right
so now in the early part of 1993
so as I said Euronymous and Varg had
been kind of there had been all this
kind of infighting for various reasons
so in August of that year
Varg and Blackthorne
who was this other guy they drive to
your honest apartment
now what Varg had said that he was going
to do was that he was going to he was
mad about this contract like a like a
financial dispute over their records and
so he was gonna give this is what he
claimed that he was gonna give
euronymous the contract back until the
[ __ ] off I don't want to do any like
financial [ __ ] with you anymore like
with the record label but what ended up
happening so he said was that he gets to
the apartment and he said that he had
suspected that euronymous had been
plotting to kill him now at his trial he
said he'd heard rumors that euronymous
was going to taze him tie him up and
then kill him on camera and like sell it
as a snuff film he said that's what the
rumor was so heat with this so he
decides that he's gonna go so when they
start getting into a fight at your on
upses apartment he decides oh well I'm
gonna take the initiative and I'm just
gonna get him first cuz he's gonna get
me if I don't get him
so he yes so he's saying Oh Euronymous
like runs into the other room like he
was gonna go get the shotgun or go get a
Taser or whatever so he decides he's
gonna so he tackles him and starts
stabbing him and he ends up stabbing him
23 times I think it was like once at the
top of the head he mostly stabbed you in
the back honestly which I thought was a
little bit it's not like self-defense he
seems like he was running away but it
looked like he stabbed him in the neck
and stabbed him at the top of the head
and [ __ ] like that and in later on it's
again he didn't really show any remorse
about it he's like oh I just I stabbed
him in the top of the head and his eyes
went like you know he's dead I guess so
yeah like I said it was 23 wins now he
said that the wounds in the back were
not stab wounds but that there was
broken glass on the floor because they'd
been fighting and that they were from
broken glass but I you know I think
forensics can tell the difference
between a broken glass cut and a stabbed
cut he carries it may be that he said
that's what I mean is it so he knows it
to maximum then give us 20 years 21 21
years there's no nerves between 20 and
21 yeah yeah so yes so that was that
whole thing so euronymous the the guy
that hit that had started the shop where
everybody gathered one of the kind of
innovators of the scene and stuff like
that got murdered so this was you know
the this was the subject of the movie
Lords of chaos which actually I kind of
want to see now even though I read some
reviews even they said it wasn't really
that good but that's mainly what this
what the movie is about it's about the
two of them and as I said Varga Kurtis
has his own YouTube channel still and
he's out of prison now he was in there
for 14 years I think he didn't serve the
entire sentence and he's still posts on
there from time to time mostly talking
about black metal talking about various
he um he's probably in his 40s I imagine
it's like maybe euronymous was planning
to kill him I don't know it's it
wouldn't be the weirdest thing that
[ __ ] happen you know I'm saying yeah
but yeah so
I still wanted to go a little bit into
now I want it's all stories you know I
watched a little bit of because I found
this well I found this one list it was
like the top 10 like horrible things
that have happened in black metal I
don't remember what site it was from but
they did a top 10 list of all the
horrible [ __ ] and it's like they had the
church burnings on there they had this
one this guy named Nicolas VAR forth I
guess he's from a band called shining
and he actually faked his death and then
they told on their fans that he had died
and then he kind of went under another
name and then like he called himself
ghoul he was like in an outfit or
whatever and then like he's on the stage
he's like but it's me I'm back from the
dead or whatever ya know and after he
after that happens like a whole like it
wasn't a riot exactly but a bunch of
violence like broke out at the concert
like there was they handed out razors to
like people in the audience so they were
like cutting each other right they were
like punching each other in the nuts and
all his guys yes that's that's kind of
Awesome
there was also and I said something
about pig heads before that's with that
band what's that band Gorgoroth
Gorgoroth good girl rocker yeah they had
a thing in Poland they did a show in
Poland that they had like all these
sheep heads I saw like some footage of
it I heard of it yeah they had all these
sheep heads like on snakes in the front
they had like kind liters and liters of
blood everywhere they just poured it
everywhere and trashed all these naked
models like crucified and all this other
kind of [ __ ] yeah here was there was oh
and there was this other one too that
was on the list because I already
mentioned that one about the the guy
that sexually assaulted his girlfriend
with the tattoo gun yeah that was the
guy his name was a Jeff whitehead he was
in a band called lurker of chalice okay
and also one called Leviathan
I remember that BAM yeah so he did that
also there's this band called um
Stella and their whole thing is that
they go to mental hospitals
and they get the patients to like come
with them to there they record in like
old cathedrals and stuff and they get
the mental patients to like scream and
like how freaked out it's like on their
records because it to be like all off
that second yeah yeah yeah so an
apparently dialogue apparently yeah
thanks dialogue there it is but but it's
Stalag but it then it's GH another GH
okay okay which supposedly stands for a
global Holocaust okay
now there's also another edge in the
[ __ ] out of this law that's what I mean
you so now there's another one and this
may not be true but this is kind of like
a black metal legend there's this guy
called than I I know I'm probably
pronouncing all this really wrong but um
what's his name
NAT NAT Ram natural something like that
he's wearing been called silencer this
is a Swedish black metal band actually
and the story goes well there's a bunch
of stories about this guy one of the
stories is that he cut his own hands off
and sewed pig hoofs on there instead
which sounds likely like you do yeah
because they're they're apparently have
been no pictures of him he's one of
those ones that like won't be
photographed
okay cuz he likes to like keep his
mystique I guess he's got hands like I
don't know I don't know I hate to
disappoint you now also another story
about him goes that in 2001 he took an
axe and like axed a five-year-old girl
in the skull I don't do now apparently
he didn't kill her like he could have
killed her but it kind of it because and
I would have thought that getting hit in
the head with an axe that would kill you
immediately but when I researched the
axe man of New Orleans that is not the
case because a lot of those victims
lived and hid they got smashed in the
head with an axe and they lived even but
they didn't remember anything actually
that's what I mean so that this is
probably like an urban legend today yeah
so the story goes that he did that and
then the cops came and then he tried to
get the cops to kill him but they didn't
like they got the dogs jumped on him and
then they make up stories well yeah
that's to compete with the guys that are
Prison yeah I mean and like I said I'm
not saying cuz obviously some of them
burn those churches down and they know
for sure that two or three of those
murders that was them so some of them do
do this [ __ ] yeah but it's kind of a
thing where they're kind of gilding the
lily you know what I'm saying it's like
you know yeah I murdered somebody but
then I also like you know sodium inside
a pig carcass or something you know what
I mean it's like they have to like add
details on they make it sound scarier
more badass or whatever they have to
make escape like right so um so this
other guy gall and he's also from I'm
putting it you said it Gorgoroth yeah
now I saw an interview with this guy and
he seemed like the nicest dude in the
world they were talking to him about um
well about various things like about his
new album and all this other stuff now
he was one of the ones that advocated
the church burning like what old shirt I
don't think he burned any himself but he
was just like yeah seems like a good
idea
furniture um interestingly he came out
as gay and so they were asking him about
you know how is that going because it
seems like it has that gay for you well
no because it seems like the scene is
like yeah yeah and especially after
fouls like how's that gay for you
stabbing that gay guy to death but he
said that well he said that he had even
gotten a letter of support from Foust
the guy that had stabbed that gay guy to
death like when he came out and as you
go I guess and I'm like that's really
weird this I found my ways I suppose you
go girl
but maybe but but I thought it was cool
because um because he was saying oh you
know I get letters from you know other
metal fans that are gay and they're
scared to come out and stuff because you
know because the scenes kind of a little
you know some aspects of it he wrote has
changed yes so he's like so I get
letters all the time saying thank you
for doing that you know it made it
easier for me to come out and all this
other stuff but then I I read like when
I saw the interview I'm like oh he seems
like a nice man and then I read this
interview that he apparently
was jailed a few times and find a few
times four for assault for taking a guy
at a party beating him up tying him up
and then draining some of his blood into
a cup and then saying he was gonna drink
his blood or making the guy drink his
own blood
so just for some random reason or
because he pissed him off I don't guys I
can't get it I guess so there was that
whole thing so I'm like oh maybe he's
not as he seemed like as he seems like a
nice guy that's other thing so yeah all
right so um I think we've probably gone
on long enough
probably long it's not well it's not
that long I think it was like an hour 45
minutes something about um yes I show
them all the videos you bought I put a
picture of it on the patreon page but if
you want me to are they behind me hand
me to hand them to me
are you are you sober now yes yeah I put
on the patreon page
well warmer at the movies like the AMC
Theaters across the street from the
Altamonte mall so we go over there and
have food sometimes like in between the
movies and they're smooth there's an FYE
over there and sometimes they have a
really big sale in the front there on
the stick for for ten dollars or they're
like two bucks or whatever because they
have a bunch of used DVDs in there and
it's like I don't care if it's DVD or
blu-ray guys so much
yeah so I got what's what is a Sin City
now some of these were gonna do reviews
on I'm not telling you which ones so
I've never seen saw so she goes I know I
can't believe he's not understand I only
like the first one though the other ones
are kind of stupid
who ever feel it's also a good one stir
of echoes you guys I was so excited when
I found this one I love this [ __ ]
movie you guys need to see this
this it got [ __ ] over because it came
out the exact same week maybe the exact
same day as The Sixth Sense
oh okay which was like a huge juggernaut
yeah we were like I'm not seeing another
guthe movie mmmm and they didn't see
this one yeah but this one is way way
better
they sent our Richard Matheson novel
it's shows are good also 28 days later
yeah which I love that cover
the way you saw that one already right
yeah Paranormal Activity the first one
I'll say look at this Last House on the
Left I hate that cover but that's the
original yes yes we did
also Black Swan which is also an awesome
movie woman in black I've seen the
original but I have not seen this this
is the remake so I'm looking forward to
that one because I love [ __ ]
old-school ghost movies and the bring
[ __ ] is you know oh it's good
alright so did I actually like this one
better than the Japanese womanized
and I say that I'd you know I don't say
that lightly cuz usually the the
original Japanese ones are usually
better than the American remix but in
that case that one was that one was way
best way better alright so I probably
forgot to mention a bunch of [ __ ] and
again if you're into black metal no
offense it's intended because I like
some of that [ __ ] - it's like and some
of these dudes are douches but most of
the dudes are fine it's like [ __ ] some
goth people are got musicians or deep
just a lot of musicians in general or
douches it just kind of comes with the
territory separates like like I said I
don't want to [ __ ] on any musical genres
because there's douches in every [ __ ]
batch for a starry night those seriously
those are super nice yes I mean we bring
them up a lot but yeah we know them and
they're super nice we like they give it
a free [ __ ] we gave them we got all kind
of ratio from then well hey I do a lot
of their stuff I do alright so we are
wrapping up episode 146 hope you guys
enjoyed this meandering musical
discussion and remember if you liked the
show like share subscribe on all your
social media if you'd like to
financially support you go to our
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
every Friday and I'll probably be doing
one or more of those movies over there
that I just showed you guys so hopefully
you'll be excited about that also we do
13 o'clock matinee which is three new
movies in the theater that comes out
every Sunday so check them out if you
haven't already and also subscribe if
you haven't already because we need more
subscribers you guys more subscribers
and that will do it for episode 146 we
will see you next time bye
kitty just trying to dig underneath the
box don't dig underneath there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]